hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
hi I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch a
highly highly we're gonna sin the
comments for Facebook messages George
Lucas reacts to Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker final trailer salty celebrity
deep fake this comes courtesy of
Collider videos our friends over there
John's actually a supposed to go on the
movie test week John has been fired I
was on Collider live last week and we're
back we've lost someone probably
socializing out there he's going around
as the mayor of Hollywood yes what we
call because every time he shows up to a
screen II he's saying hi to everyone
that energy he's so II so pleasant like
I'm just I would be exhausted secret
racist though I think everyone so they
are a good friend so I'm sure we're okay
with covering this have been a lot of
deep fakes lately I'm just excited to
see this is actually funny you're not
must be considering the amount of people
been asking for this alright let's check
it eat alright guys well the background
that we're gonna use we can do like a
green screen we bring in a green that
looks very real wow so good Carbonite
oh this is great it's great because I
didn't make it
ultimately I'm not to blame Electro's
say her sister died or something trying
to throw space grenade and they saved a
bunch of horses or something Camino look
at that that's where all the cloners
live my life Ralph McQuarrie's piece is
just picking it on that big kids you
ever see see a star star come out of the
ocean well you're gonna see it now
[Music]
there's a hairdryer a robot just soccer
balls are all about a hairdryer let's
just supposed to put a dildo in here
look this is Merry Christmas
ha ha you know what that's not as it's
the sound of a thousand executives just
taking a [ __ ] oh man this [ __ ] will
end
thank God put it out of its misery oh
there's a space horses ooh good thank
God
think how they tied up that that gem of
a storyline so really this makes attack
of the clones look like Citizen Kane
take a light saber to the SAG is head
and just cauterize that thing as it's
fine
just a bit yeah I know the ending of
this film I'm gonna spoil it for his
boiler alert here's how the film ends go
ready at the very end
Star Wars dies well I think my favorite
part about the trailer was the beginning
when it said that my name so the
Lucasfilm the whole idea of the hero's
journey was you have someone who is
leaving home for the first time into a
new world and they don't have any skills
and they fail time and again and I guess
in the new series they've rewritten the
hero's journey to where the hero is
already perfect you know at this point
people have asked me if I would like to
do more Star Wars though I was really
deeply hurt by the peoples you know when
those movies came out they were very
risky for me because they were more
operatic they were they were more poem
poems
it wasn't about acting or logic or any
semblance of traditional filmmaking in
any way that we've ever known it since
the beginning of cinema and the fact
that people for some reason didn't like
that was very upsetting to me so I just
said I'm out so I think with this film
Star Wars
but I laugh and ahead Bob is so accurate
oh man Roman des I got lost in that I
mean other than you know it's it's a
deep fake so you're gonna notice some
things like a little off like around the
eyes especially I don't know who at
Collider is doing this whenever you go
to Collider it's like this warehouse
studio and they got like multiple rooms
and multiple sets and then there's
always like three sections usually
Dennis saying is in one of those
sections where I'm like what the hell's
going on no this was Dorian was it yeah
okay yeah
Dorian's black they Cody faked it how
his hands are real there's other black
guys pants all right I did get lost in
this because after a while I stopped
viewing it as a deep fake this is really
George's mineral George Lucas yeah
bitterly watching the stars really I got
lost in that and I started taking
everything he was saying as factual
George Lucas thoughts you know what I
mean yeah you can imagine him saying
these things and feeling it's pretty
aligned with a lot of what we've heard
George Lucas say so far white slavery
I've sold them to the white slavers that
take these things and this is the best
Raisa Skywalker reaction that has come
out thus far yeah hey I really wish like
the company would like hit them up and
be like can we use this reaction oh yeah
this was savage just in the cracks he
was making rope he dropped something
the plot oh yeah of a guy who you know
he's handed this franchise
I like the idea with these characters of
the George Lucas character of this guy
who has handed off this franchise is so
disappointed with what's happening you
barely even remembers the events of what
has happened in like force awakens last
gen I think when he's talking about rose
and like her sister that one thing about
about being glad somebody else is making
it cuz this time I'm not to blame that I
bet that's a real thing the Georgeson
probably feels that's what the whole
review was about when he was talking
about after the reaction it was a tone
poem about any type of filmmaking that
ever explored until they get to do this
this is incredible I well next time I go
to Collider or you're supposed to go
pretty soon we got to find a PD yeah
this was Wendy Lee right here the whole
time there's a great George Lucas has to
create the rock all sorts of people I
would love to hear like a podcast with
George Lucas not some like quick red
carpet interview or some press interview
but like a full-on podcast with George
Lucas after rise of Scott Walker comes
out to know what he thinks of the the
whole new trilogy yet see what all this
here what all the thoughts are in depth
I think that would be I think a lot of
you all tuned over that that's like the
only podcast I would ever react you
totally destroy Johnson yeah I hear he
hates last Jenna anyway that's not a
surprise this was great good job clutter
videos I could see why everyone was
asking us to check this out this was
really well done I got lots of new you
guys can subscribe to Collider as soon
as you can keep a lookout for whatever
John and I are back there could
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell I would like to end
this with a patron of the day shout out
to a man named Jake Stewart specifically
chose you for this buddy because we talk
weekly on patreon and he did a patreon
patron on patreon plug page rail a
couple months ago I want to make sure
you were the one who's told me this
we're talking about stars born you said
you're making your way through the
nouvlesse collider released of a hundred
essential movies for budding
cinephiles considering this is a
Collider video since Jake is one of the
people who's actually honoring this a
hundred essential movie viewing list I
wanted to shout you out because you've
been a great supporter of the real
rejects you've clearly been an
incredible supporter of Collider videos
I want to give you a list of a hundred
essential episodes of TV you have to
watch
and I got nothing here is a terrible
joke this is a terrible joke it's
terrible I'm gonna make you a list of a
hundred deep fakes you need to watch
it's gonna take a long time though
because there probably aren't a hundred
deep fakes such an awful joke Jake give
me a massage man I could use a massage
from you I'll come to you and get a
massage ah to you
you